- [Jay] Good to see ya.
(crowd cheering)
- I mean, keep going.
- Thank you. Thank you.
That's great, guys.
- [Kelly] You made it.
- I did make it.
- Last time we didn't
quite make it, but yeah.
- Well,
and before that I was sick and you came.
I feel like were passing
ships with the show.
- I know. Ships in the night, yeah.
Just different accidents
happening. Yeah, yeah.
(Kelly giggles).
- I know.
- Yeah, yeah.
I know. Either I had Covid
and you were covering for me
or there's a motor, so
there's always an accident.
You're good. You look great, though.
- This is a brand new face.
- [Kelly] Great job. Great job.
- It is. It's unbelievable.
What, what happened,
I was working on a car
and I got a face full of gasoline.
And it caught fire.
I had been eating a flaming hot Dorito.
When I bit into it.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
What a commercial.
- It set my set my face on fire.
No, no, but it, it was,
yeah, it was, it was
it was interesting.
All third degree burns.
It was pretty bad.
- You can't tell at all.
- No, no. You'd think there'd
be a zipper here or something,
but no.
- [Kelly] No, that's what I'm
saying, like that's crazy.
- No, this like a brand new,
only for the second time in my career
am I the new face of comedy.
(Kelly laughs)
I got it once in the eighties and now I,
now I get it again.
That's a brand new ear.